Beyoncé à Dubaï elle voulait que ce soit
totalement secret c'est sorti ça fait un
scandale regardez
[Applaudissements]
on s'assoit sur ces beaux principes
contre une grosse somme d'argent c'est
en tout cas ce qu'aurait fait la
superstar Beyoncé selon la communauté
LGBT en se produisant à Dubaï lors de
l'ouverture d'un hôtel de luxe
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour la coquette somme de 24 millions
d'euros
ça c'est clair devenu ces dernières
années l'une des icônes du mouvement
LGBT la diva a donc suscité la polémique
en chantant dans les miracles qui n'est
pas franchement connu pour être une
terre de tolérance puisque
l'homosexualité y est interdite par
exemple une performance qui lui a valu
un lynchage en règle sur les réseaux
sociaux
au cours de ce jeu controversé la fable
de Jay-Z a même dû adapter sa playlist
pour ne pas choquer son auditoire pas
d'imme le féministe par exemple à la war
on the world dans ce pays où les droits
de la femme sont quasi inexistants
[Musique]
et encore moins de chorégraphie ultra
sexy dont Beyoncé a pourtant secret
[Musique]
alors que son dernier album Renaissance
était un hymne à la différence ce
concert à de quoi interpeller la
polémique ample de plus en plus mais
pour le moment la star n'a pas souhaité
réagir alors Beyoncé lâché sur les
réseaux après un concert à Dubaï
comprenez-vous la colère des femmes
alors un bref résumé
un bref résumé et après des mots qui a
pris ça très à coeur va vous expliquer
donc Beyoncé a touché 24 millions de
dollars pour cette prestation pour un
choc exceptionnel uniquement sur
invitation 1500 invités étaient présents
des influences des influenceuses des
mannequins donc Nabilla iris mittenaere
Kendall Jenner des gens très chic
donc téléphone portable photo vidéo
était totalement interdit mais
évidemment
ça a réussi à sortir on a filmé
l'événement je sais pas si c'était dans
le sujet du coup c'est ce qu'on voit
maintenant ou pas je ne sais pas c'est
ça
[Musique]
pour l'ouverture d'un hôtel
et alors il y a
et alors les femmes sont en colère et
vous allez comprendre pourquoi c'est
hallucinant ce qui s'est passé des mots
en fait il s'avère que son dernier album
qui s'appelle Renaissance qui est sorti
à pas très longtemps elle l'avait dédié
à son oncle Johnny qui est décédé des
suites du VIH qui était d'accord et elle
avait décidé de faire un album
à ce concert là pour lequel on rappelle
quand même touché 24 millions de dollars
et pour le cas le rappelle aussi que
l'homosexualité là-bas est un crime
passible de 10 ans de prison voilà elle
a elle n'a pas du tout chanté cet album
là elle a chanté les chansons pour
lesquelles on la connaît et elle a
décidé de ne pas chanter ses chansons là
qui était en soutien LGBT donc tous les
fans étaient très très en colère n'ont
pas compris à quoi elles jouaient mais
moi si je peux me donner mon avis je
suis persuadée qu'elle va que tous les
que que qu'elle va reverser le cacher
je pense aussi les 24 millions de
dollars pour la recherche pour que le
VIH je suis sûr et certaine qu'elle va
le faire
quelques tweets un album spécialement
dédié à son oncle gay pour finir par se
produire à Dubaï dans des pays les plus
lgbt-food au monde
pas si de la peine de mort paie ta
Renaissance Beyoncé première album
incroyable qui a dédicace aux femmes à
la communauté LGBT dans ses discours et
blabla et hop dès qu'il faut de l'argent
à Dubaï elle s'en fout complètement
c'est quoi cette voilà c'est tout ce
qu'on dit les gens c'est je préfère vous
laisser parler vous parce que j'ai j'ai
un détail qui n'en est pas un c'est que
ça faisait 4-5 ans qu'elle était pas
montée sur scène elle revient sur scène
pour un truc comme ça qui est
personnellement je trouve indigne elle a
été particulièrement connue justement
pour ces choses sur scène qui sont
extravagants incroyables un peu à la
Madonna donc ça c'est une chose et
deuxième chose et c'est là où je pense
que Déborah a tort c'est que si elle le
fait pour une somme d'argent ça veut
tout dire alors qu'elle est mariée au
premier rappeur milliardaire qui
s'appelle Jay-Z donc elle aussi
ah si parce que c'est toujours des fous
quoi
tu en as besoin ils en veulent toujours
plus donc voilà donc si tu te défendre
elle se défend en disant que c'était le
seul endroit où elle pouvait faire le
concert de ses rêves c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a tellement d'argent avec de la
pyrotechnique et c'est son père qui a
dit ça mais c'est son père qui a dit ça
c'est complètement faux mais mais ils
vont bien trouver un truc à dire
de mettre de côté ce pays justement en
emmenant des célébrités mondialement
connues comme ça ça permet de mettre la
lumière sur ces problèmes qui sont le
droit de l'humains sur place à chaque
fois qu'on parle du concert de Beyoncé à
Dubaï on revient sur ses problèmes mais
pour moi ça sert à rien de les mettre de
côté
ça sert à rien de mettre ce pays de côté
en mettant des gens comme ça
mondialement connus dans ce pays ça
permet de mettre en lumière les
problèmes qui s'y passent alors que si
on les met de côté
du coup on en parle pour une fois c'est
loin d'être con ce qu'il dit
parce que alors du coup attendez alors
j'ai écouté la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
par exemple jamais on a autant montré du
Qatar mois avant en disant il se passe
des trucs pas top etc
Dubaï c'est pas les mêmes lois sur les
femmes et tout ça attention déjà je
répondais à Laurent parce que là le
bilan pardon mais c'est eux qui sont
absolument ravis et tu dis mais du coup
on en parle on en parle mais oui ce
qu'on a vu sur tout c'est le côté
clinquant bling bling mais ça leur fait
grandir mais tu les as vu où les
problèmes
alors en fait Benoît selon toi comme
maître Gims va toucher plusieurs
millions pour chanter la Coupe du Monde
il nous rend service non mais après tout
mélanger
on peut aussi rendre service du coup la
communauté merci Maître Gims
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on ferme les
yeux on les laisse là-bas on leur rend
jamais visité et puis terminé mais à
chaque fois qu'on y va on file un pognon
pas possible à ce pays qu'on a déjà du
pognon et on rentre bien sûr on rentre
en disant c'est c'est 4 millions
juste on est injuste avec
moi et surtout les pets de télé du monde
comme ce soir on parle de ce pays on
dénonçant des trucs qui vont pas et puis
qui les prendraient pas moi
oui qui les prendrai pas vous faut
arrêter d'être hypocrite 24 millions de
dollars après ton elle peut faire aider
une cause n'importe quoi on fait ce
qu'elle veut 24 tu peux pas résister à
24 millions de dollars je suis désolé
écoute-moi bien sur mes neveux pour 24
millions d'euros tu me demandes d'être
la tête d'affiche et de représenter
l'Arabie Saoudite ou une femme n'a pas
le droit de parler à un homme quand on
ouvre la porte ou les femmes sont non
pas les droits des hommes ou l'écologie
je t'en parle même pas ils sont en train
de tout tuer et où les homosexuels sont
passifs de 10 ans de prison mais jamais
explique-moi bien
[Applaudissements]
tu sais pourquoi tu sais pourquoi parce
qu'il y a une chose qui est très
importante dans la vie il y a l'argent
il a dormi moi tout ce que je veux c'est
réussir à dormir la nuit quand à 30
millions et que c'est de l'argent sale 3
mois
c'est pas une boîte de nuit ou un
produit de merde que tu as vendu il en
parle de gens qui vont en prison
qui me regardent que j'aime et je leur
rends bien avoir des valeurs
vous disiez pour 80 millions d'euros moi
je suis prêt à balancer des heures dans
un bouquin sur ma famille
[Applaudissements]
c'est que chacun a un prix à un moment
donné c'est vrai que bon chacun on va
dire
elle est milliardaire Sophie elle est
d'accord elle est milliardaire mais à un
moment donné on lui propose 24 millions
d'euros je fais une toute petite nuance
entre alors les Émirats arabes etc et
Dubaï voilà Dubaï il y a quand même une
certaine liberté etc elle est arrivée
pour chanter c'est l'hôtel Atlantique
dans une chaîne d'hôtel qu'on retrouve
aux États-Unis etc et qui est plutôt une
chaîne d'hôtel on va dire à part donc
après on prend le pays mais elle a
travaillé pour une chaîne d'hôtel
moi j'ai tourné à Dubaï pour un dock
j'ai eu l'Office du Tourisme on était en
FaceTime et la fille me dit vous comptez
tourner qui et je lui dise qu'on
tournait deux personnes qui étaient un
couple gay ah non monsieur
l'homosexualité est interdite quand tu
entends ça face à face ça fait mal mais
oui tu as envie de lui dire mais pauvres
t'es autorisé toi pauvre conne tu vois
ce que je veux dire tu n'existe pas
alors j'avance un peu les stars qui ont
chanté au Qatar je ne juge pas mais je
l'ai je l'ai diplôme DJ Khaled Calvin
Harris clean bandit Sean Paul j'essaie
de faire avancer le monde et vous êtes
là et vous vous vendez pour 10 balles
pour votre sœur